we begin in Zimbabwe where pools have
just opened in presidential and
parliamentary elections we are looking
at live pictures there outside a polling
station in Harare we should tell you
that President Emerson got nangagwa is
seeking a second five-year term he is
campaigning on promises to create more
jobs and upgrade crumbling
infrastructure now his main Challenger
opposition leader Nelson Chamisa he is
hoping that the frustrations about
corruption High inflation unemployment
will encourage people to choose him
instead now Al jazeera's Haru matasa has
been following all of these developments
she's outside a polling station in the
capital Harare and Haru tell us a little
bit about what the turnout is like where
you are we know the polls have just
opened
well where I am in the capital Harare at
this particular polling station the
numbers are pretty decent they're many
tents around you the different polling
stations where people go and vote so you
won't see the long long lines because
there's so many teams people can go and
line up at what they do is they come
here first they check their name is on
the voters roll they get told which
particular tent they go and votes inside
then they're going to join the queue and
they go in and vote this part of Harare
it's uh in a Township called embari one
of the oldest townships here it's uh one
of the a very poverty type area where a
lot of people are struggling to make
ends meet you see those Flats there
that's where many many families from
this area live some of them share one
room because if they were trying to save
rain because they don't have the money a
lot of people here are struggling some
of those apartments don't often have
running water or electricity life is
tough here to make ends meet a lot of
people because they don't have formal
employment they sell stuff on the street
from second hand clothes to use car
parts anything they can find just to try
and feed their families the economy the
High Cost of Living and inflation are
big concerns for many voters here in
Zimbabwe so given that life is so
difficult
is there a lot of Engagement in terms of
voting or are a lot of people just kind
of giving up and is apathy a concern
you know what I've seen with the
selection I like the previous ones I've
covered is that the campaign period
leading up to now has been unusually
quiet people have been asking is there
an election going on what is happening
normally by this time you'd have had a
lot more arrests a lot more people being
beaten up by the police and state
officials that isn't so much the case
anymore it's only been isolated
incidences is it because people are
don't want to come out and vote who
knows but someone said that you know
what a lot of people are quietly
registering to make sure they can come
out in huge numbers to vote on vote
today we already know in a couple of
hours at the end of the day uh what the
turnout will likely be but the young
people have been told to come out in
their numbers so people are waiting to
see how many or the demographics of the
lines what it'll look like would it be
more young people or more of the older
generation Who come out and vote and
what is the sort of main issue that
people say that they are hoping will be
addressed in this vote
it's poverty I mean the real main issue
here is poverty and the economy and the
High Cost of Living I mean living in
Zimbabwe is tough there are times when
prices are basic Goods just go up every
week so how are people supposed to make
ends meet there was a time when there
will be no electricity for most of the
day it's improved somewhat but it's
still a challenge some houses don't have
regular running water from Council Taps
it's a struggle being in Zimbabwe if you
don't have work it's even harder if you
don't own foreign currency it's even
more difficult people just want to have
a winter selection to address all these
needs because ultimately regardless of
who you support people say they just
want the economy to turn around quickly
all right harumatasa covering the voting
there outside of a polling station in
Harare thank you so much I know we'll be
keeping across all of the voting
throughout the day thank you